hi so thanks thanks Rahul and thanks to
the organizers for the of this workshop
for asking me to give this talk so what
I'm going to be talking about today is a
very simple result so it's a compression
algorithm for AC 0 mod p so i'm going to
define these terms to begin with so i
should say that this 45-minute talk has
less content that many other 15 minute
talks have seen so you should feel free
to interrupt and ask me questions and
things like that so okay so so what is a
compression algorithm so let me just
kind of briefly review something that
we've seen quite a few times in this
program if especially if you've been in
the boot camp so this is an example of
what is called a meta algorithmic
problem so what is such a problem so
generally an algorithmic problem where
the input or the output has something to
do with the model of computation a
circuit a formula or something like this
this is what we think of as a metal
gorinna problem so intuitively
understanding efficient algorithms for
this problem involves understanding
certain computational models so examples
of these problems are quite a few
examples very natural examples so
circuits site is definitely an example
there your input is some sort of boolean
circuit and you want to decide whether
it's satisfiable or not like is the
function computer by the circuit
identically 0 another example is similar
to circuit SAT but in the algebraic
setting is the polynomial identity
testing question again your input is an
algebraic circuit or an arithmetic
circuit and you want to decide if the
polynomial computer by the circuit is
identically zero or not so the problem
that we are going to be looking at is
likely different from these and similar
to one that Eric was talking about in
stock yesterday so he talked about the
minimum circuit size problem here the
input to the problem is not a circuit
the input is the truth table of a
function right so your boolean function
on n bits so the truth table of this
function is a boolean string of length 2
to the N and that's the input and say
you have a size parameter K that's also
part of the input and the question you
want to answer is does this particular
function have a circuit a boolean
circuit of size at most
okay so that's the minimum circuit size
problem yeah so all these problems are
really well studied in the literature
the lots of results about them so the
problem i'm going to be talking about is
a slight variant of this rope the
minimum circuit size problem you can
think of it as a kind of gap version of
this problem okay so you have let's say
a class of circuits that you're
interested in I don't know it could be
AC 0 and this for the result that I'm
going to talk about we're going to be
look at AC 0 with mod p gates right and
so the compression problem for this
class of circuits was defined in this
paper being last year think all the
authors of this paper are actually in
the audience so nice okay pretty good
and so anyway the input to this again is
a truth table of a function so you have
a 2 to the N bit string it's the two
table of a function on any dates right
and what you are promised so it's a
promise problem you promised that this
function has a small boolean circuit
from this class so let's say it has a
small AC circuit you know that okay and
the problem is okay find a small circuit
from this class well not necessary a
sufficient let's go find some small
circuit for this okay so given the
promise that this function already has a
small circuit construct some other small
circuit write a non-trivial a small
circuit I get to what that means in a
second it doesn't necessarily have to be
from this class it could be a general
circuit okay in a sense you're
distinguishing functions with small
bullion circus on this class from random
functions because random functions do
not have small circuits okay so what is
non-trivial e small mean yeah your non
trivial e small means something that is
better than what you expect for a random
function so it's known that most
functions don't have any boolean circuit
or size less than roughly to the N by N
and if you can do significantly better
usually we will be doing that's a
significantly better than this in a
sense it'll be 2 to the N by something
that's super polynomial in n if you can
do something like that then you really
can distinguish such functions from
random functions and so that's an entree
very small circuit any questions about
the definition you just small circuit
what is just a small circuit so the
input is actually a truth table right
and obviously no power right right okay
right so yeah the promise is that it has
let's say polynomials a circuit yeah so
I'll be a little more formula second
right so let's say polynomial size
circuits to begin so this is how the
problem is the problem of this division
commander that's right this a harder
problem okay and the interest in this
problem is that similar to the meta
algorithmic problems we saw in the last
slide this is intimately related to a
question of lower bounds okay so like
Ryan's result for circuit side and a
many other results so we know that if
you can actually come up with
compression algorithms for interesting
class of circuits that will imply lower
bounds for this class of circuits a
lower bounds in an expert like some kind
of thing that you know there is the
general notion of physic relighting
distinguishing and prediction so if you
can distinguish from random does it give
you some kind of circuit may be at least
a nondeterministic circuit or some crazy
thing like that so distinguish I mean
this seems intimately related to natural
proofs and things like that but so but
that's exactly what that's about even
very good then you get a circle over
Bell for NX in a sec away what going to
ask is you can sometimes you get an
algorithm that solves the easier problem
the fun of distinguishing from random
and make it into compression algorithm
maybe by using no game yo so unknown
that any net pro property gives you a
compression of it yes even if it
somebody could allow like the general
circuit to even have like to be not that
amazing
to something about what you could just
guess and check it oh yeah Adam ok so
anyway okay so this is the interesting
for example these kinds of compression
algorithms so even solving a very
special kind of promise case of the
minimum circuit size problem kind of
gives you non-trivial lower bounds ok so
that's why we interested all right so
let's just start off so I just want to
kind of build intuition for the results
that already know let's start with a
very simple case of the compression
problem yes they are similar yeah so the
proofs are similar to the circuit SAT
stuff so imagine that the parameters are
yeah quite similar yeah so the authors
of this paper feel free to correct me if
I'm wrong ok ok so let's start off with
the compression problem for dnas right
so it's a very special case of AC 0 so
just depth two circuits you're writing
the circus just an or of terms each term
is just an end of literals so this is
actually a very well studied problem so
you have your given the truth table of a
function you promise that it has a dnf
of sizes you want to construct a
non-trivial small DN f4f and this is
just the dnf minimization problem that i
think is fairly well known right so how
does one go about solving this problem
well there's a very simple connection to
the set cover problem so you can just
use set cover algorithms to actually
solve this problem pretty well so let's
just go through that ok so what is this
problem so you're given a boolean
function so this is my kind of attempt
at drawing the hypercube here this
diamond is the hypercube so you have
your boolean function that splits the
hypercube into the 0 inputs and the one
inputs ok and what you know beforehand
your promised beforehand is that this
boolean function does have a dnf of
sizes so it has a circuit of this form
right each of the ants in this circuit
computes an end of literals which is
that sepsis sub cube in the hypercube
and therefore you know that the ones of
this function can be written as the
union of at most s sub cubes that's what
it looks like ok and what you want to do
is actually find a small union of sub
cubes that covers the ones of the
function
okay so pretty straightforwardly this is
actually just a set cover problem right
so you're given this boolean function f
you can construct all these sub cubes
that are contained in a one set of F so
recall that your input size is 2 to the
N so looking at all these sub cubes
there may be 3 to the N sets of cubes
but that's still a polynomial number in
terms of your input size right so you
just write down all these sub cubes and
then run maybe let's say the greedy
algorithm for set cover or something and
there's classical kinds of results that
tell you that the greedy algorithm is a
good approximation algorithm in the
sense that it will output an answer
that's at most a log the universe size
far from the optimum okay in this case
universe size at most 2 to the N so
there's an order and approximation you
can get this in polynomial time okay so
what does this give us it tells us that
if you start with a function f the dnf
of sizes and let's say this s is not too
close to 2 to the N so let's say it's 2
to the N minus T where this T is large
enough so that this becomes
significantly smaller than 2 to the n
then this kind of very simple greedy
procedure of covering the ones of F with
sub cubes will give you a dnf for the
same f of size roughly to the N minus T
again right so if you are much smaller
than 2 to the N to begin with you get
something that's much smaller to do ok
you're right it's just sighs n times s
yeah so but you are essentially the
savings remain more or less the same
play you don't want s to be 2 to the N
by n in which case you don't get
anything right yeah okay so already this
very simple results can be used in
conjunction with kind of strong results
in the literature about circuits to
obtain non-trivial compression
algorithms okay and this is a work done
by Chan at all so this is what they
observed is that if you start with a
circuit if you have a result of the
following form now you have more
powerful class of circuits not
necessarily DNFs if you know that
circuits from this class of size s can
be converted to DNFs of non-trivial
small size right then you can just use
this algorithm and obtain a dnf not just
a general circuit a dnf of non two very
small size for your function and already
this works for many simple very nice not
not very simple class of circuit so for
example
zero right so if you look at ac0
circuits or sub exponential size so just
to recall an AC 0 circuit is a bounded
depth circuit so it's no longer depth to
but some constant death it's made up of
and or and and in or gates and you up
literals feeding in other leaves so for
AC 0 circuits of sub exponential sighs
it's known that such circuits can be
converted to DNFs right these DNS are
not very small but they're still
non-trivial e small so they have size 2
to the N minus T for a reasonably large
t okay and these are recent results of
impact layer so Matthews pittore and
hast add from a few years ago and so now
using these results you actually know
that these circuits are small dns and
therefore you can run the dnf algorithm
will get a non-trivial small circuit
okay so this is the exact bound that's
obtained so I just want to kind of state
this because I want to compare it to the
bound that's obtained for AC 0 with the
parity with parity gates and mod p gates
so bound obtained is the following so
you start with an f which is promised to
have an AC 0 circuit of size s and let's
say depth D okay so the algorithm that I
talked about kind of obtains a circuit
of this for this same function of size 2
to the N by some discount factor Capital
m where its capital M is this funny
thing ok so it's exponential in n over
log s over n to the D minus 1 it's
really precise yeah and what's kind of
interesting about this and something I
want to stress is that the regime in
which this algorithm is non-trivial the
regime in which the circuit output is
non-trivial e small is exactly the
regime in which we have lower bounds for
ec 0 right so the strongest lower bounds
we can prove for AC 0 are of the form 2
to the n to the 1 over d minus 1 and in
roughly this regime the the size the
circuit output is much smaller than 2 to
the N by okay so roughly in the regime
where we have lower bounds we have
non-trivial compression algorithms okay
so this is a really nice result and this
is actually not very surprising because
it goes through the same machinery that
we used to prove lower bounds so this is
kind of what he was talking about
yesterday when you said that every lower
bound that we know gives an algorithm
right so the lower bounds that we know
for a c0 kind of yield this algorithm in
particular and other algorithms and
we're going to see that the same thing
happens 4a c0 with more to gates
okay so this is the result for ec 0 so
also results for many other circuit
classes so for example you can talk
about de Morgan formulas formulas so now
these are circuits that are not bounded
in depth but they're kind of tree like
the underlying graph is tree like and
you're made up of and or and not gates
so for de Morgan formulas of size much
smaller than n to the 1.5 you can
actually show that these can also be
converted to DNFs of small size and this
again follows from kind of classical
results of support of sky about random
restrictions and their effects on yet on
formulas there is we you actually need
slightly stronger versions of these
results and these are due to ruffle and
strengthening due to the authors of the
chain at all paper so you can do this
and therefore you can again convert
these into small DNFs non-trivial small
DNFs you can use the algorithm come from
the non-trivial small circuit okay so
also a bunch of other results about
other models of computation that I'm not
going to get into in very great detail
so it turns out that you can use further
ideas not just the dnf idea I told you
further ideas based on memorization and
things like that and push these bounds
up for example this into the 1.5 can be
made into the 2.5 and they're also
results for general formulas branching
programs and other results okay so but
the focus of the rest of this talk is
going to be about this AC 0 kind of
compression algorithm and whether it can
be pushed to slightly stronger constant
depth circuit classes so any questions
about nexus 4 yeah how we know how this
thing compares with the set based
approach to prove our bouncy one better
than the other
so I don't know of any formal result
that says that SAT algorithms black
compression algorithms or vice versa
though in every case that I know that
there is a non-trivial compression
algorithm there is already a non-trivial
SAT algorithm so for example you on the
AC 0 mod 2 then I'm going to talk about
Ryan also has SAT algorithm for this
circuit class is roughly the same kind
of improvements for acc we have SAT but
not compression yeah okay we'll see for
the spooky remove all right well society
needs some kind of yeah we get it for
some slightly larger canals should its
show so go ahead that you never let me
get the sea compression algorithm yeah
absolutely no recommend you like and one
who decided I think you need a quadratic
size blow up and at least the way the
proof is written right now so I'm not a
I'm not hundred percent sure that you
don't need any overhead okay so any
other questions all right so okay so the
question that kind of motivates us now
is that can be confident I'll goes on
for more powerful class of circuits ok
and the circuits we are going to be
looking at our just the AC 0 circuits
that I talked about in the last slide
but you now augment them with the power
of some sort of modular computation okay
so specifically for the rest of this
talk I'm going to talk about AC 0 with
more two gates right so more two gates I
essentially gates that can do some
modulo 2 so their parity Jets they are
kind of depicted with this funny 0 plus
sign right and again we are sticking the
constant depth regime and the questions
okay can we prove similar results here
okay and definitely the techniques are
have spoken about so far conversions to
DNFs and so on don't really work in this
setting because even the simple parity
function does not have BNF of
non-trivial small size so we need some
sort of new techniques to handle this
and so the main result is kind of just
to contrast with a chain at all thing is
that we get similar results for AC 0 mod
2 okay so
suppose I start with a function that's
promised on AC 0 mod to circuit of size
s then we can in some polynomial into
the n time find some circuit for the
same function of size 2 to the n over m
where this em again is non-trivial
exactly in the case where we know not to
be a lower bounds of this class so it's
exponentially in n over log s to the two
times t minus 1 so exactly in the regime
that we have lower bounds we get
non-trivial compression and so it turns
out that this result also works for for
AC 0 mod p where p is any plan so right
so i just wanted to kind of state these
results formally for but for the rest of
the talk i just think of d as some
constant so we look at some constant
depth circuit and let's assume that s is
polynomial so s is n to the order 1 d is
a constant and in that setting what we
really want is a circuit of size 2 to
the N or exponential in n over poly log
n that's the kind of regime that will be
shooting for all right yeah and as i
said earlier so the results that go into
proving a result of this form and again
closer it closely tied to the lower
bound results that we know for these
circuit classes and the lower bound
results that we know for these circuit
classes have to do very are very closely
related to polynomials okay so let me
just briefly review some material about
polynomials and then I'll go to the
description of the result so so we are
going to be talking about multi linear
polynomials over the field f2 right so
we have n variables x1 to xn which will
normally be bits right and we're looking
at multi linear polynomials that take
values and f2 okay so for example things
like this so the thing about a multi
linear polynomial is that is a very
special case of an AC 0 mod to circuit
right so if I multilinear polynomial
like this then that's really a depth to
circuit it's got a parity gate on top or
more to get on top and what are feeding
into it are just monomial so monomials
just ends with variables feeding it to
them okay so the very special kind of
depth to AC 0 circuit okay in particular
if the polynomial has degree D right so
if if all the terms are feed into the
motto gate are all degree D that means
each of these ions that we're looking at
in the circuit over here involve that
most D variables which means that the
size of this circuit is bounded by
something like n choose t such a number
of binomial coefficients up to D ok
right and the interesting thing but
polynomials and how they relate to AC 0
more to other than the fact that a
special case is that we know that these
polynomials can actually be able to can
actually be used to approximate
arbitrary functions in ac0 more to ok so
the sense in which polynomials
approximate functions is the following
so I'll say that a polynomial P epsilon
approximates a boolean function f if
it's equal to F and all but an epsilon
fraction of the locations so on a random
input is equal to F with probability 1
minus epsilon so the results we know
about polynomials and ec 0 mod 2 or the
following so there's a very famous work
of raspberry from back in the 1980s
where he showed that polynomials of low
degree can epsilon approximate and
arbitrary AC 0 mod 2 circuit okay so you
think of this is a non-trivial result in
the sense that it says that any AC zero
Matto circuit which could be a really
large depth can be squashed down into a
depth to circuit as long as you're
willing you're ok with the circuit
airing in a few places ok so we might
have some arbitrary circuit which is
computing let's say of polynomial size
which computes some boolean function the
polynomial will compute a boolean
function that's very close to the
boolean function computer-based circuit
so it'll be a few errors you are
possibly on the zeros and on the ones
just a little bit but the degree of this
polynomial is not very big okay so the
degree of this polynomial is only
logarithmic in the number of variables
right as it and as a result of what we
saw in the previous slide right so if
you have a degree D polynomial the size
of the depth to circuit you get is only
n choose at mostly right so if you get a
polynomial of degree poly log n then
this gives you a circuit a depth to
circuit of quasi polynomial size that
kind of approximates your boolean
function so it is equal to a boolean
function of most of the inputs
so this is what we know about AC 0 mod
two circuits and the question is can we
leverage this in order to come for the
compression algorithm and if I tell you
something like this about 80 more to
circa this actually leads to so if I
tell you this about a general circuits
from this class a very natural kind of
approach to a compression problem is the
following right so I know that I'm given
a truth table and promised that it has
small circuits from this class so I know
that there is a lower degree polynomial
approximating my circuit right it's
equal to my circuit almost everywhere so
what i will do is i will try to find
this load degree proclamation right okay
so i'll find this approximation i have
this approximation with me then i know
at what points it's airing because i
have the truth table or the function i
have the polynomial i can just compare
them i know at what points is airing
right the size of this polymer is not
very big as I say it's a depth to
circuit it's a low degree polynomial
it's not very big what i can do is kind
of just attempt to fix the polynomial at
the points where it's airing right so i
can start with the polynomial get my
hands on a polynomial and once I have
this polynomial I can just try to fix it
I can say okay these are the error
locations are kind of brute force the
pot and you can just fix the polymer
these other locations and that will give
me an overall a circuit of size the size
of polynomial I had to begin with plus
the locations that kind of had to fix
right so I had something like epsilon
times 2 to the N locations to fix I'll
fix those say
one over m to the local n to the log n
like the because you're just trying to
save like a circuit of size 2 to the N
over that's a good thing for me right so
2 to the N by super polynomial is fine
right so i can take epsilon 2 b inverse
super polynomial right ultimately
epsilon to be close to inverse
exponential but yeah so for now just
think of epsilon is being just in verse
24 polynomial one over n to the log N or
something right so this is a very small
collection of points so I just kind of
fix the polynomial I get at all these
points so i'll change the polynomial say
ok here's a brute force circuit that if
the input lies in this error said the
beautiful circuit will do it for you
otherwise you just delegate the
computation to the polynomial the
polynomial do it for you and your fine
ok so they're kind of very natural kind
of approach to take yeah and the only
problem with this approach is this step
2 ok so how do you find this polynomial
P and it's not clear how to find this
polynomial P so this was the approach
suggested by Janet already and it's not
really clear how to find this polynomial
P really this this can be stated as a
problem of my bill decoding reed-muller
codes and certain regimes but the
distance parameter you are looking at is
really much more than the minimum
distance okay so it's kind of decoding
in a funny regime of this well study
reed-muller code but it's a different
kind of regime than what people actually
look at but you're promised you know
that there is a code word in this regime
right but the problem of finding this
code word is not entirely clear so this
is a very natural approach but kind of
breaks down because it's unclear how to
carry out this procedure are actually
finding the polynomial so our way of
kind of fixing this over before I gone
is this kind of thing clear I mean this
yeah okay so our way of kind of
circumventing this is to change the
notion of polynomial approximation okay
will change the notion of polynomial
approximation that will blow up the size
of the polynomial but actually to make
the polynomial much easier to find it
will just be the problem of solving a
system of linear equations or something
so what's the different notion of
polynomial approximation we are going to
use so we're going to use a kind of
one-sided
polynomial approximation so let me say
that a polynomial so as opposed to
epsilon approximation let me say that a
polynomial is a certifying polynomial
right it's a certifying polynomial for
my function if whenever the polynomial
is one the function is one and that's it
ok so the polynomial that I'm ticket so
this again is my function so polynomial
that I'm thinking about is going to be
zero on all the zeros of my function
right and it's going to but the end is
going to be 1 therefore possibly only in
a small subset of my once so it
guarantees me that when the polynomial
is 1 the function is 1 but I don't have
any guarantees on the error ok so the
polynomial the way I've defined it in
fact it could be 0 everywhere so that's
a certifying problem so that's when one
additional condition it's a non zero
problem so I have a non-trivial kind of
certificate of being one ok so
definition of this is clear ok so just a
one-sided kind of approximation so this
has been studied actually quite a bit in
the literature already so it's closely
related to a real version that was
introduced by as far as I know by aspen
is beagle first andrew ditch in a kind
of classical paper in the 90s so this
particular definition was kind of
introduced in the name it was called
week degree when it was introduced by a
paper of Fred greens in the mid-90s ok
it's also be studying in the crypto
community quite a bit they call it
algebraic immunity all right yeah so
again so this is similar to our previous
mission of approximation only they get
rid of errors but on the plus side which
is kind of one-sided we know that when
the Paula when the function is zero the
polynomial 0 so it turns out that you
can say something about how well these
polynomials approximate functions in ac0
mod 2 but in order to understand when
this such a result is non-trivial we
need to understand what we can say about
arbitrary functions ok so any function
it turns out any function has a
certifying polynomial of degree at most
n by 2 so contrast is to the fact that
any function can be written as a
polynomial of degree at most n that's an
obvious fact right but it turns out that
any fun
Shin has a certifying polynomial of
degree at most n by 2 right so n by 2 is
kind of the trivial regime here right
and so there's a little bit of a star
here there's a small caveat you need to
assume that the function is kind of
balanced or it has more once than zeros
in order please make a statement like
this but let's assume that this is too
funny function to for almost any
function so this is the kind of
non-trivial regime and if you take for
example this certifying polynomial of
degree at most n by 2 and write it down
as a circuit like we've been doing just
write it down as a brute force depth to
circuit you will give a get a kind of
local circuit the local circuit will
compute the function correctly here and
here right but the local circuit would
be really big it will be of size the
number of monomials of degree at most n
by 2 which is more or less 2 to the N
all right so it turns out that if you
known now that the function actually has
a small AC 0 mod 2 circuit then you can
actually improve on this kind of trivial
result so this is what we know for any
function so in a kind of theorem that we
hide the result we had a few years ago
so swastik go party and I could show
that if function in fact has an AC 0 mod
2 circuit of polynomial size then you
can improve on this n by 2 a little bit
ok you can actually get certifying
polynomials of degree n by 2 minus n
over poly log N and this minus n or poly
log in is kind of crucial right because
you know n by 2 is trivial it's n by 2
minus something much smaller than n by 2
but that's crucial that's that's what
makes it not to be right and if you
translate this again into a depth to
circuit right you get a depth to circuit
where the size of the circuit is a
number of monomials of degree at most n
by 2 minus whatever but that's much
smaller than to today don't get just one
volume of me like that but you get many
of them that's cover the
you're absolutely your two slides ahead
of me absolutely that's what we are
going to do ultimately so these
polynomials are going to be our
replacements for sub cubes from the dnf
case alright so okay so right so as I
said so if F has an ec 0 more to circuit
of polynomial size and you are
non-trivial e large a non-trivial small
certifying polynomial yeah and the
difference between this and the epsilon
approximations that we talked about some
time ago is that you can actually find
these certifying polynomials okay so
that's the advantage right the kind of
computational advantage to using these
things and why is it that you can find
these certifying polynomials but it's
not really hard to see it's just solving
a system of linear equations so I want
to find a polynomial say that is
certifying for my function right so I
know that there's a certifying
polynomial of degree at most D this
theorem guarantees me that so what I
want is a function a polynomial which is
0 here and non zero here right imagine
the process of just writing down this
polynomial so this is what the polymer
is going to look like so for every
monomial of degree at most D there's a
coefficient right and now I treat these
coefficients as kind of variables that I
need to find I need to solve for for
each point in the 0 set here i need the
polynomial to be 0 at this point so that
gives me a constraint on these
coefficients i can write down the system
of constraints and i can solve right so
for each of these is there is a
constraint i can solve then discuss this
solution is some sort of vector space
and what I want is a nonzero element of
this vector space okay so a priori note
that the number of variables here yeah
the number of variables here it's
something like the number of monomials
of degree at most e yeah so it's much
smaller than 2 to the N but the number
of constraints here is let's say let's
say the function is balanced the number
of constraints here is like 2 to the N
ok so you a priori you have like an
overdetermined system homogeneous system
of linear equations and there's no
reason to expect that this has a nonzero
solution but the theorem guarantees you
that there is a nonzero solution ok yeah
and we will see the proof of this
theorem again it goes back to the
razbera of polynomial approximation but
once you have this theorem you know that
there is a non-trivial solution you can
find this montival solution polynomial
time
because you just want to solve a system
of linear equations so any questions
about this yeah and can you make sure I
guess you can also make sure that it's
nonzero on any particular point right so
we will have to go to it's it's
important that it be nonzero on
different points when we cover the
entire space yeah so we that's the kind
of thing we just still need to get to
right absolutely yeah yeah absolutely so
yeah okay so right so so we have the
system of linear equations that we can
solve and so the set of all solutions to
this linear equation form some sort of
vector space right and it turns out
there are nonzero elements in this
vector space and we pick one of them
that gives us a certifying polynomial ok
so again so now we can find some
certifying polynomial but this is not a
circuit that actually computes our whole
function it computes our function very
locally it computes it correctly on all
the zero inputs computes it correctly on
some of the one inputs so but we want to
compute it on all the one inputs how do
we do this and the idea again goes back
to DNF so what we're going to do is try
to kind of cover the ones of this thing
by a bunch of certifying problem right
so what we want to do is find lots of
certifying polynomials I kind of cover
this entire region okay and if you do
this with a small number of certifying
polynomial then we are done ok so when
you try to prove something like this you
will naturally run into some sorts of
issues yeah and the reason for this is
that what we are doing the space of
solutions we are looking at is defined
by a bunch of linear constraints right
so you have one linear constraint for
every point here and the bad thing about
having these constraints is that they
can imply other constraints right so for
example forcing it to be 0 here and here
might force it to be 0 here and that's
not something you want because if that
happens then you'll not be able to cover
this point with any certifying problem
yeah so this is one of the problems we
need to overcome and there's one other
so let me just show you a couple of yeah
if you have that every point is possible
to have zeros and one at this point then
you take a basis then a random when
you're coming
you know basis elements will cover about
half the space absolutely but there may
be points that are never covered by any
solution so those are the really the
prompt points what you're saying is
aptly right so if there are points which
are not kind of force 20 so we're going
to get to it in a couple of slides
anyways okay all right all right so
there are a couple of kind of problems
with this approach and the first and
more serious problem is that having all
these constraints for points on the left
side can force linear combinations here
to be zero so which means that every
certifying polynomial that I look at
every certifying polynomial is always
going to vanish at these points here
okay so i will call these points a set
of forced points f4 forced so these are
these those points on the right hand
side among the ones of the function so
that every certifying polynomial
actually vanishes at these points ok and
these points are really bad because no
matter how many of these certifying
polynomials I take I'll never be able to
cover these guys ok so we need to say
kind of argue that F is small ok and
once we argue that we kind of be able to
brute force over F and kind of just fix
the circuit at these points but then
there are the other points ok they're
these points at these points it is
possible that certifying polynomials are
nonzero so for every point here there is
a certifying polynomial that's nonzero
at some there is some certifying
polynomial that's nonzero but we still
need to be able to cover all these
points with a few certifying polynomials
yeah this is a second kind of thing and
this is what kind of Russell was talking
about and what he was saying was that if
you know that there's a point here which
is not going to force 20 then you can
actually find certifying polynomial
cover all these points kind of quite
efficiently all right so anyway so there
are these two issues so what I'm going
to tell you is that the first issue it
turns out to slightly more serious and
we'll need a kind of literature some
work from the mathematics literature to
actually solve this problem but the
second problem is actually very easily
circumvented bill and you can solve it
quite easily so let me tell you how to
handle the second issue first ok so you
have some small set of forced points
assume that this is we forget about
these now we need to cover the rest
using these certifying polynomials right
and it's kind of easy it's just a linear
algebraic argument to show that if you
take a run
certifying polynomial write a random
polynomial from our space of certifying
polynomials it's going to cover every
point here with probability a half right
so you just because I Adam polynomial
there is a polynomial that's nonzero at
some point here and the random
polynomial is going to be non 0 with
probability a half this is just some
simple linear algebra but once you have
something like this what you can do is
just choose a few random polynomial so
you choose one polynomial that covers
roughly half the space another another
and pretty soon you're done covering the
entire space ok so if you pick something
like order n many random polynomials
like this with high probability you're
going to have covered the entire space
except for these really bad guys so you
take order n such polynomials take the
or of these and that covers that covers
everything except for the bad guys which
we still have to show to be small so
this kind of gives you a randomized
algorithm to do what we want and you can
easily be randomized this algorithm
using some simple error correcting codes
or something ok so let me just kind of
yeah I'm and safe ok ok so let me just
kind of summarize our approach before I
tell you the main part of the argument
it is ok so so what is the argument
right so we started off with these
rasberry of approximations which are
like two sided error approximations to
our boolean functions we said that we
can't really find these approximation so
using these approximations not a good
idea for the compression algorithm so
now we are looking at one side of
approximations the certifying polynomial
approximations and we need to argue that
there is a small degree certifying
polynomial for our function assuming
that it has a small circuit but this is
just the analysis but once we have this
right and we don't just neither d
there's a small degree certifying
polynomial we also neither the number of
forced points the number of really bad
guys is small but once we have these two
facts what we do is we can have just
obtained order n polynomials from the
space of certifying polynomials that
covers all but the really bad points
right for the really bad points what we
do is we just kind of come up with a
brute force dnf that outputs one on
those really bad points and putting
things together we get a circuit for the
entire thing ok
so the size of this circuit is roughly
the size of these certifying polynomials
and not too many of them the N of them
so roughly the size is certifying
polynomials plus the size of us the
number of forced points and the number
of force points is really small then
you're done so the only thing to do is
to kind of argue that argue the first
line of this that this actually happens
so since I have only about five minutes
left I'm probably not going to get
through the entire argument but let me
just give you an idea anyway it's very
very simple okay and again it goes back
to a kind of classical result of a Swiss
beagle first andrew ditch regarding how
to do this ok so just recall so when we
want to construct certifying polynomials
for our function we really want to solve
the system of linear equations where the
number of variables is far fewer than
the number of constraints yeah so it's
not a priori clear that solution exists
but it turns out that using these
raspberry of polynomial approximations
these two side of the polynomial
approximation that we are talking about
some time before you can drastically
reduce the number of constraints you
need to look at right and you can start
with an kind of under what
overdetermined system of linear
equations and make it a very
underdetermined system of linear
equations and definitely then your
guarantee the solution exists ok so
what's the idea behind this so more
formally you start with an epsilon
approximating these raspberry of type
polynomial approximations of really low
degree right so these are really low
degree polynomials but they can air on
both sides so they can air here they can
add here ok and let's take the error set
of this polynomial so the shaded region
and the error set is guaranteed to be a
small subset of the hypercube something
like epsilon times 2 to the N so the
certifying polynomial that we will
construct is going to be kind of the
product of this polynomial P with a
polynomial Q that's kind of just 0 on
the error set so what we do is we find a
polynomial Q of some small degree that's
zero on this error said okay and again
in order to do this we have to solve the
system of linear equations but note that
the number of constraints now is much
smaller than 2 to the N it's only
epsilon times 2 to the N right so you
start off with a kind of very large
number of constraints right but now you
are solving you're going to a different
system which has a very small number of
constraints and now if you choose your
parameter
to carefully it does not have to be very
close to n by 2 it can be slightly far
from n by 2 then you will have at least
as many variables as linear constraints
and then you will be able to find a
non-trivial solution okay so and once
you have this polynomial Q and your
original polynomial P the final
certifying polynomial is just the
product of these two things so it's Q
times P so if you look at this
polynomial Q is zero everywhere here
right p is zero in this region so the
only place where this polynomial can be
nonzero is right here right so this
polynomial are being non zero means that
Q is non zero which means the polynomial
P is not making an error and the
polynomial P is outputs one which means
we are right here and then now if you
kind of just work out the parameters for
this and set epsilon suitably it's going
to give you the right hands so this is
more or less how to construct a
certifying polynomial for our boolean
function you can actually also construct
a certifying polynomial where the force
set is small so this is what we really
need for the algorithm right we actually
also need to say we don't just need to
say that the certifying polynomial is of
low degree we also need that the number
of points where such polynomials are
forced to be 0 here is small in order to
do this you kind of just go through the
same analysis but you are a little more
careful and you need an additional
design ok so again what we want to do is
start with a raspberry of polynomial P
and then multiply it with the polynomial
Q that's 0 on the air upset okay right
but again being 0 on the error set means
that you're going to be 0 in a bunch of
other places yeah this is always the
problem you're yours you have a system
of epsilon times 2 to the n constraints
but this might imply other constraints
you might get other constraints so
polynomial Q is forced to be 0 here but
that forces it to be 0 in a bunch of
other places okay and all we need to say
is that these bunch of other places is
kind of small okay that this set is
small because once this set is small in
all the other places Q as a chance of
being non zero so Q times P has a chance
of being non zero so the certifying
polynomial has a chance of
Nnanji so the bad set whose cardinality
we want to bound is really a subset of
the set f prime which is a set of points
where q is forced to be 0 right and once
you state the problem like this it
actually becomes a very neat algebraic
problem and it's actually been studied
quite well in the literature so let me
just tell you what the solution to the
problem is so you have some set e yes so
so if you kind of lost track of the
register proof this is actually a very
neat statement that you can just take
home from this talk so you have some
subset of f 2 to the N of small size
that's the epsilon times 2 to the N
right and what you not want to know is
you want to know what's the size of this
set f prime so the f set f prime is
defined as follows all polynomials of
some degree that vanish on e are also
forced to vanish on the set of points
and f prime yeah so being 0 on e forces
polynomials of this degree to be 0 and a
bunch of other points and how large is
the set of points and this is kind of
very very natural question is kind of a
question about closure of polynomials
and how large they can be right but it's
kind of degree fixed kind of closure
right and it turns out this exact
question has been studying the
mathematics literature and we know
exactly the bound okay so this is a very
recent result of two authors knee and
Wang okay and but it actually also
follows from some earlier results in the
combinatorics literature so which says
the following that the fraction of
points in the hypercube that lie in F
brime right so the fraction of points
that are forced to 0 is at most the
ratio of the number of constraints that
we have to the number of variables right
so II the error set yeah the number of
variables in a system of linear
equations right right yeah right so a
number of monomials or the number of
variables in a system of linear
equations right it's something like n
choose at most D 2 is the number of
coefficients of monomials of degree at
most D to write and E is a system of
constraints because we are forced to
vanish on E that's something we want
okay and the number of consequences of
the system of linear constraints which
is the cardinality of s prime the
fraction of that as a fraction of the
entire space is less than or equal to
the number of constraints divided by the
number of variables right so if by if
you choose your parameter suitably you
can ensure that the number of number of
variables in your system of linear
equations is much larger than epsilon x
to the n write something like square
root epsilon times 2 to the N this
forces your system not just to be kind
of under determined but very
underdetermined so you have many more
variables than constraints and in this
setting this result kind of says that
the faction of forced points is actually
very small as this so basically what
you're saying is that if you choose d2
so you have two lak extra constraints
hey by a fraction k not take K times
more constraints in some sense yeah oh
not just area it's not i sir it's a
ratio of the number of variables number
so that you induce it also very fraction
k exactly that's exactly right so yeah
right so if you're the number of yeah
variables the number of coefficients is
twice the number of constraints the
number of force points that most half
the fraction of the entire space yeah
and so on okay so it's a very neat
result so if you think about it it's a
it's a kind of considerable extension of
the kind of trivial result that says
that if you have more variables and
constraints then you are not forced to
be zero everywhere you have a
non-trivial solution we will sing
said that if you other day if you added
like to to the end to the day and over
and tell constraints you can reduce to
today on over 10 points but then they
said k times e yeah exactly that's right
that's exactly right thank you okay and
so now yeah so once you have this result
it's more or less plug and play from the
proof that I told you earlier so you
just choose your parameter D to like
this and then your final certifying
polynomial is Q times p where p is that
as purple ok so that's more or less all
I wanted to say so yeah so let me just
summarize with a small list of open
questions right so so the compression
algorithms that we here given here so
they are interesting but they're so far
the compression algorithms that we have
kind of are in line with the circuit
lower bounds that we already have okay
so can you come up with compression
algorithms for other or stronger circuit
classes for example even reproducing
Ryan's result for ECC 0 the compression
algorithms would be very interesting
okay and one kind of question I have
which is not quite in this line but
motivated by the proof of the theorem
that we just saw is the question of
compression algorithm so this funny
circuit class so you take AC 0 circuits
but you put a majority gate on top or a
threshold get on top okay and the reason
this class is kind of interesting is
that these certifying polynomials or
these one-sided error polynomials were
first investigated for lower bounds to
do with this particular circuit class so
this is circuit class for which we do
know lower bounds and they involve
similar such polynomials right but I
don't know how to mind that lower bound
in some sense for a compression
algorithm that comes up with some sort
of computational problem that I don't
know how to handle okay so that's also
an interesting question and finally I
think this last result we saw on the
previous slide this result of me and
wank is actually really interesting it's
a very natural problem for which we have
a title kind of inequality and I would
really like to see other applications of
this earth so let me stop here thanks
do some deep whooshing no no it's
actually quite simple it's so so yeah so
it actually has to do with so it solves
an extremal problem optimally and the
extremal problem is the following so if
you have a if you are looking at let us
say some to to the are points in the
hypercube right and you're looking at
you fix some degree parameter D what's
the set of 2 to the are points that
minimizes the dimension of the vector
space of degree D polynomials restricted
to these points right so look at all
degree D polynomial stick to this to the
yard points that's a vector space what's
the set of 2 to the yard points that
minimizes the dimension of the vector
space it turns out the answers are sub Q
of that size and that's it so once you
prove that and that is this can be
proved this is actually being proved at
least I think in three places right so
once you put plug that in it
okay yeah so let's tie for a short break
so let's thank recount again